hello everyone how are you guys doing
it's a fantastic pleasure for me to be
here with all of you guys this is
spanish grandmaster pepe and i'm
extremely happy to be here in my third
grandmaster residency for the saint
louis club
and yeah so
just uh see a lot of people in the chat
already
they're in the youtube chat also some
people coming from chess 24
to this lecture and today
we're gonna uh check some game between
magnus carlsen the world champion
and fabiano caruana the current wall
number
two sorry just please let me know that
everything's fine regarding
audio and video just uh some comments on
youtube will help
for example and then we are ready to go
to examine this fantastic chess game
today's end game class so as you guys
can imagine we're gonna examine an
endgame that occurred in this
fantastic game between carlson and
faviano caruana everything working okay
jorge kimmel is saying
so the more questions we have in the
chat
the more fun we'll be and you can give
me your opinions
questions whatever you guys think and
yeah so maybe we should start already
checking this game so altibox norway
chess
first otb chess tournament at least
top chess tournament elite chess
tournament
after the pandemic or we should say
while the pandemic still going on right
so
at least in spain still crazy probably
in many places
in the world so let's see if this
nightmare ends
pretty soon so we can go back to play in
otb chess tournaments right
so where are you streaming from i'm
streaming from spain i'm actually
based now in ibiza it's a beautiful
island i am from the south of spain
city called granada but i moved to ibiza
for the summer just you know chilling
and the beach
just working from home so there are not
so many chess tournaments right
i can also do my engineering work from
from home so
everything's fine and uh okay yeah it's
2 30 a.m in spain but you know i have to
adjust to
the us time right so but it's cool you
know i like a vampire
okay guys so let's start analyzing this
game between carlsen and faviano caruana
this corresponds to
round number four where magnus carlsen
goes for d4
and not f6 from fabiano caruana
c4 and e6 and as you guys know
most of these guys with the black pieces
they're aiming to go for the nimzon
indian defense
actually one of the most solid
approaches with the black pieces
there are several ways to avoid the
ninzo indian defense for example
g3 intend to go for the catalan also
knight f3 and here black has several
options you can go for the bogo indian
defense
you can go for c5 and then we reach some
uh
benoni positions for example after d5
you guys know how this b5 move is called
so in which system are we right now
after the move
b5 yes i guess you know
so exactly ariane
blumenthal this is a
pretty interesting opening with the
black pieces i like the move e4 here
by the way so i am analyze
deeply this variation this gambit with
ee4 pawn
uh okay this is another story right okay
so not a three
but in this position magnus carlsen
allows
the nimzo indian defense and he plays
knight to c3
okay so black plays bishop b4 of course
there are many many options here for
black
available c5 and d5 again
we transpose to we enter in the benoni
and also d5 right entering in the
quinn's gambit
positions but okay bishop b4 the nimso
indian defense
this is a really natural move black
develops a piece and
black is ready to castle shirt in the
next move
also black is ready to give up the
bishop
but in return probably is going to ruin
a
wide spawn structure after taking on c3
right
okay so here again different approaches
for white you can play knight f3 you can
play
e3 you guys know what's the idea behind
e3
there are two ideas actually behind the
move e3 in many positions you want to go
bishop d3 and also you can try to
develop the knight
to e2 in these types of position not f4
f4 it's actually not a very good move
there but the idea
in many positions just go knight g to e2
and
later we can push this bishop with a3 in
case black takes on c3 this knight is
ready to take back on c3
that case we won't ruin our pawn
structure right so that's why knight g
to e2 it's really great
idea too but in this position sorry
this position magnus carlsen goes queen
c2 it's a really natural move
just intending to protect this knight on
c3
in case that black text on c3 again we
won't ruin the pawn structure
by the way we have time at the end of
this lecture we will analyze
artistic games artistic puzzles sorry
from
ready ready is it was one of the best
chess players in the in the beginning of
the 20th century
and also he gave some nice contributions
to opening theory with the move93
but okay queen c2 here black goes sure
castle
again different options d5 here c5 is
also a possibility
even d6 but okay sure castle from favi
and a3 from magnus skelton
just kicking this bishop on forcing this
bishop to take on c3
and of course here we take with the
queen right so we don't want to check
with the pawn
precisely this move queen c2 was just
made to take with the queen on c3 and
we keep our structure healthy right
here black plays d5 and bishop g5
okay and in this position it's true that
we have the bishop player with the white
pieces
but in return we have not developed
all our pieces on the key inside so
that's why
it's a perfectly playable footblack and
we'll have some troubles we we need a
lot of tempe actually to develop our
kingside right
why not bishop t2 of course bishop g2 is
another possibility here
it's a really playable move so that's
completely fine uh a z
but okay bishop between c2 sure castle
a3 take stakes and d5
as we were saying we are still we still
have a lack of development on the key
inside so that's why black
in many cases in medications they want
to open the position up
so they want to fight against our kin in
the center so d5
and here bishop g5 from magnus carlsen
d takes c4 taking this pawn so
we have to take this pawn back and
what's the worst piece
for black basically this bishop on c8
because now
it's not enjoying uh the position
because
it doesn't have a proper diagonal so
that's why black plays b6
now this which can join the body by a b7
or a6
yes mustache this is live so you can ask
me
any questions that you want or
give me your opinions talk about life
talk about love
and uh whatever
yeah it's a sad bishop right but now
caruana wants to activate this bishop
by a6 so here there are two main options
and one is to go knight f3 the second
one is the move that magnus carlsen
plays
rook d1 which is a little bit more
flexible
and now black plays bishop a6 now the
first question for you guys
where would you go with the white pieces
there are many
healthy moves here let's say for white
but there's
one that probably is a little bit more
precise than the others jorge jimenez
says queen a4 why what's the reason
before behind sorry going queen a4
queen c3 queen c2 yeah queen c2
is fine queen c3 is fine but i like
queen a4 you know what because
black wants to develop this knight to d7
at some point yeah so if we go queen c2
just knight b to d7
and then at some point black is gonna
get ready to strike in the center with
c5
so that's why with the move queen a4 we
posed some troubles
to black player right because now it's
gonna be tough for him
to develop this knight to d7 at least he
will have to lose
another tempo by playing bishop b7
first right or something like that in
this position
caruana plays h6 asking this bishop
where he wants to go would you take an
f6 in this position
or would you retreat that little guy to
h4
or to c1 maybe d2 maybe e3
yes i'll be working here for uh two
weeks at least until the end of the
of this month so we'll be analyzing
games of the day
uh i'll be playing against you guys in
some battle blitz sessions so we're
gonna have a lot of fun during this
two weeks so where will you go
with the bishop to h4 would you take on
f6 maybe
retreat the bishop and maintain the
bishop bed that's a very nice idea jorge
jimenez
there's no reason to take an f6 here
because now black just takes and then we
had a nice fish we have a fantastic guy
there so white
to give out the bishop pair for nothing
so bishop b with bishop h4
that's precisely the best move just
keeping this spin on f6
and still black has some troubles
and now fabi went for queen d7 intend to
trade queens in this position
but i want to ask you what will you play
with the white pieces if black goes
bishop b7
again there are different options here
and let's see what you guys say
so i'm gonna give you like four or five
candidate moves
so let's say knight f3 let's say knight
h3
e3 f3
queen c2 back no bishop h6
come on azad don't sacrifice the bishop
there there's no reason you know
that's too much right
this is not christmas we shouldn't give
our opponent
too many gifts right e3 on f3
c2 queen c2 e3 mr moustache
well here of course you can play knight
f3 and nothing happens but i really like
this
setup with f3 and e4 now we got the
bishop pair and we got a nice
center right we start a beautiful nice
center so for example let's say black
plays knight d7 we play
e4 and then we are fighting with this
structure
we are fighting and against this bishop
on b7 so basically it's doing nothing
against in
this strong structure with the pawns on
e4 and on f3 that's what that's right we
blocked the bishop on b7
and then we are ready to develop our
pieces let's say bishop d3
knight e2 even this bishop can come back
to f2 to reinforce the center if
if needed right and then of course we're
gonna go long castle
and black is lacking of break points
right so a black
cannot go c5 easily so there's some
x-rays
in the d-file with rook on d1 and also
e5 is difficult to achieve
so that's why this position was
extremely extremely good for white
at least in practice it's very tough to
play with the black pieces
so that's why fabiano caruana says you
know what i'm gonna offer
the trade of queens with the move queen
g7
and here yeah that's right f3 and e4 is
kind of a beanie plan
plus limits bishop b7 i agree with you
marcin
so queen g7 and here
magnus goes queen c2 again if we take on
d7 this actually
uh favors uh black's development right
because black anyway wants to
bring this knight out so after queen d7
let's say knight g7 and black has
all the pieces out on plane look at this
king side you know still this knight in
g1 bishop on f1 the king in the center
so black is ready now to strike with c5
and then
get a nice counter play so that's why
magnus went for queen c2
and fabiano caruana offered again
the trade of queens queen c6
and now yeah there's still theory as
jorge jimenez is saying
but there is always a reason behind the
the theoretical move so that's why
it's always great to to try to
understand
why these strong players go for these
moves right
so queen c6 and now what would you play
here with the white pieces again
would you trade on c6 would you go back
with the queen to b1
well everything is more or less playable
so there's no big mistake here that you
can make
but magnus went for queen c6
well this is natural move you go for
queen b1 maybe it's just too passive
right
maybe this is just too passive because
black is going knight b to d7 and then
you know at some point black is gonna
strike with c5 and
i don't see the reason why to play uh to
put sorry all my pieces in the
background right so
trade on c6 trading on c6 looks like
very very reasonable so
knight takes c6 and magnus now destroys
a black spawn structure on the key
inside right
so it goes for bishop f6 in this
position
and if you go e3 straight away so black
can take on f1
king takes f1 and now knight d5
so here white is not enjoying anymore
the bishop here
and black is completely fine at some
point it's going to remove this knight
from c6 and then it's going to strike in
the center with c5
and the king is on f1 so not so well
played
and i would say this is just okay for
black right so that's why magnus carlsen
takes on f6
gtx f6 and now e3 bishop f1
key f1 and then so
if you could choose what uh
would you what would you take the white
pieces or the black pieces and why right
so guys wish me good luck tomorrow i'm
traveling
to denmark and from there to sweden to
play in the swedish league
let's see what happens you know i
actually this is my third tournament
the first tournament i played during the
pandemic it was the national
championship
and i ended up in a lockdown
because you know as you guys know
there's this pandemic and then one guy
from the tournament tested possibly
positive and then we all had dinner with
him
but luckily nothing happened but i had
to
retire from the tournament after round
two
so hopefully everything goes all right
and i can help my team in the swedish
league
so i will take white because of double
f pawns and weak pawns on c7 i agree
with you marcin so
the better structure is for white here
so only two islands
right so one island and
sorry two islands right and black has
three islands so one
two islands and three islands so in the
long term
black could suffer actually in this in
this kind of position
so magnus is the kind of player where
you give him
just a tiny tiny advantage and then he's
able
to uh to put a lot of pressure you know
he takes
his screwdriver you know he starts
playing with you around
and this is what he does in this game
against fabiano caruana
so fabiano plays knight a5 intend to go
c5 as we were saying
so 93 still c5 is not a good option here
right right because after taking on c5
then this pawn is going to end up
a little bit weak so that's why faviano
calls for knight
c4 will be there
any otb chess tournaments in russia well
the candidates guys the candidates is
uh coming back the first of november as
you guys know
it was cancelled or postponed in march
due to the pandemic but now the first of
november is coming back
so 50 of the tournament was completed so
let's see what happens
and uh so knight c4
for example after rook a to c8 we can
just play
kini 2 and after c5 we can just take on
c5
rook takes e5 and now white plays
and wins with the move b4 somebody at
home could be saying come on stupid
spanish guy
what are you saying pepe i just have
rook c to check
but the thing is there's queen sorry
king d3
and now there is a double attack on the
knight on a5 and on the rook on c2
and basically black has to resign in
this position
is wang hao playing uh actually he
should be played but he was complaining
right he was saying
something to defeat it and i don't know
what's going to happen so
i guess they're still in negotiations
but it didn't smell
well right let's see what happens in
this candidate tournaments
i'm so looking forward to it so we can
uh get to know who's gonna be uh magnus
carlsen
challenger so knight c4 from fabi
he is forcing actually magnus to put a
passive rook on b1 so magnus is forced
to go for this
otherwise after b3 so the pawn on a3 is
just falling
so rook b1 from magnus carlsen and now
the plan with the white piece is
actually quite simple
kiwi e2 followed by rook h to c1 just
putting pressure on the c file
as as somebody there was saying for
example noble nouvelle
it was saying that c7 is weak and this
is actually true and we can put a lot of
pressure on the c file
so fabiano caruana went for c5 he wants
to get rid of
this weakness and king e2
from magnus carlsen well of c4
knight takes d4 the position is a little
bit better for white just
a little bit better due to this
structure but fabiano caruana decides to
activate his rook by playing rook f2 c8
and rook h to c1
is he karuna camura playing in the
candidates no icaru didn't qualify you
guys know there are
different ways to qualify for the
candidates the uh there are
a couple of spots given by raiding
there's
a couple of spots given in the world cap
also one spot uh from the uh
grand swiss organized by feeder where
the best 100 players in the world
compete
and also there's always a wildcard right
so the organizers can decide to include
a player that they want
so maybe jorge jimenez will be the next
candidate now there are also some rules
right so the
the player invite the invited player has
to be above
2700 i believe so i think alekseyenko
was the invited player because he
really did a great a great tournament
for example in the grand swiss
and russia was organized in this
tournament right it makes sense yeah so
if the united states
organizes tournament makes sense to
invite another u.s player
yeah so spain is organized in a
tournament so
it makes sense to bite spanish player
right so
i completely understand so knight d6
from faviano caruana
and now d takes e5 b takes c5 and
another weakness
has arose in this position the pawn on
c5
but in the other hand black has
the b file to put some pressure on the
b2 pawn
right so who's your favorite for the u.s
championship
between so and karo any surprises well
i'm a big fan of both of them so i think
anybody can win also lanier dominguez i
guess he'll be playing
and he's a good friend of mine you know
i visited him last time i went to saint
louis because
normally guys this grand master
resiliency is done
on site right so i go there to st louis
spend a couple of weeks hang out with
people right there and it's a lot of fun
but this year we have to
you know make it this online so but
lanier dominguez sleeps around there and
he's a good guy very humble and probably
it's a
i mean i'm rooting for him for in the us
uh chess championship right you guys
know he was born in cuba
it's a great country i mean it's uh
nice people friendly people linear is
one of them
so rook c2 from magnus cats and of
course here the plan is just to put a
lot of pressure on the c5 phone
but black is not going to make life easy
so
keen f8 just knight d2 controlling c4
and now carolina says you know what i'm
going to go anyway c4
and the thing is after rook b to c1 from
magnus carlsen
fabiano caruana goes rook a to b8
and it's not going to be that easy for
white to capture on c4
right why because now if white takes on
c4
let's say yeah knight takes e4 knight
takes e4
rook takes c4 boom boom boom ba-boom
rook takes v2 and then this is
completely equal right after the move
like group b5
but magnus says you know he's always
tricky and then he plays
king f3 and now
do you think that white is ready to take
the opponent on c4 in this position
jorge moustache ariane
ahmed
you think white is threatening actually
to take the pawn on c4 or not
there's no problem for black because the
pawn on b2 is just hanging
so a move like king e7 is possible in
this position or even king g7
let's say king g7 what do you think
about this move
well you gotta be extremely careful in
this position
because now you can actually take the
pawn on c4
yeah it's true that the pawn on b2 is
gonna fall but also the pawn on a7
so knight takes c4 rook takes e4 rook
takes e4
rook takes e4 rooks me to rook c7
and now there's no way of protecting
this guy so
a5 rook c5 a4 rook c4 and finally you
grab this guy here
has a juicy sauce this one on a7
it's true what uh chess king is saying
it might be a draw at the end
but it's gonna be a lot of suffering for
the black player
and it's not gonna be that easy to make
a draw because the structure is not
symmetric
on the key inside if there's a pawn on
g6 black has better chances but with the
pawn on h6
and the rest of the guys on the f file
on the e5
white has better chances to win this
game
so that's why
fabiano caruana in this position has to
find the
best move and he didn't um
what would you play here with the black
pieces instead of king g7 you have
better ideas now that you know the plan
once that
once again has gone away from e2 so
there's no rook b2 check
white is threatening to take this pawn
on c4 followed by
taking that guy on a7 so what should we
do here with the black pieces
it's a really tough move so yeah
cheskin gives a brilliant idea that
actually
was the idea that faviano caruana
employed in in his game
which is uh c3 sacrificing upon we'll
we'll come to that in a minute
but kidney 7 doesn't work jorge because
of the same reason right
knight c4 takes takes and then at the
end of the day there's rook c7 check
and rook takes a7 so
c3 is very very interesting but magnus
had everything calculated actually
he was uh he was saying that c3 might
not be the best move
he was saying that in the confessional
room you guys know there is a
confessional room
in this ultibox norway chess also for
example
this uh sync field cap where the players
go and then they
give their opinions about the game why
during the game so that's why it's
pretty pretty amazing
so the best move here was rook c5
rook c5 what's the idea behind this rook
c5 well after knight takes e4
knight takes e4 rook takes c4 now you
don't take on c4 but instead you go
rook f5 the point is
that now whenever the king goes you take
on b2
and f2 is going to be a quickness right
you see the difference
and if rook takes a rook f4 sorry you
can take on f4
and now white has two options if white
takes with the key in this rook b2
and f2 is under attack it white takes
with the pawn that is rook b2
and now you go rook c7 boom rook b3
check so this is why rook c5 was
so precise in this position but uh
okay fabiano carona goes for c3 now
magnus
carlsen says you know what i don't i
don't believe in any of this
i'm just gonna grab this guy here and
then enjoy life
and fabiano caruana's idea was to play
sorry
knight c4 probably er on the first side
okay he didn't go for knight c4 he went
for c3 in the game i was doing spanish
commentary in chess 24 and
he played he just played very quickly c3
and then
after manuka after macro story took on
c3 now he starts thinking
for a while and probably he realized
that after knight c4 the position is not
that easy for black
because now knight takes e4 rook takes
e4 and now there is a brilliant move
here
for the white pieces of course black's
idea is just to go
rook b3 just to capture an a3
so it bla white goes to protect that guy
on a3 now
c3 will fall greetings from holland
nice country i used to visit a lot delft
for example
dang hack so well i love waffles in the
netherlands you know
and uh actually it's a really
interesting country for an engineer for
a civil engineer you know i was about to
uh to work in in a very important
company which is called deltares
which works with flood risk management
of course
flood is flood risk is a
it's a really important topic in the
netherlands
but i finally ended up working in
germany as a researcher so
finally i didn't go to the netherlands
but
would have loved to so what's the idea
here for white
now that you guys know the plan for
black which is rook b3
what should we play here well magnus
explained
what was his idea rk1 this is very very
passive
mustache yeah because now after rook b3
what are you gonna do
you cannot protect both weaknesses you
gotta play actively actively sorry
not passively yeah active active active
moves
so d5 that's right mark and tracy
johnson
wow this looks like a perfume yeah
johnson's baby you know
you guys use johnson's baby in your
country
that was my favorite perfume you know
until i was 25 yeah
not just as a baby you know but
johnson's baby was so cute you know my
skin was
so nice you know um
all right so rook d2 or rookie one so
rook d1 is actually a really good move
for example after rook b3
now you play rook d7 you take on c3 i
can just take on c3
so hello enrique from spain what's up
man so if black takes on c3 we just take
on c3 and take on a7 we
reached the same kind of position but
also
if black takes on let's say a3 what
what do we play sorry with the white
pieces here in this position this is a
key move again
i'm sure you guys gonna spot that
now it's really important move that's
right aryan
you know everything ariana probably
maybe you are ari and tarry
ari and teddy here following the
lectures as you guys know arie antares
is playing
precisely in this tournament he's a good
he's a good guy actually i
we shared him in the swedish league no
it's not aryan tariq
but it's aryan gutla and
he finds the best move which is rook b2
the idea is
as you're saying just double rooks on
the seventh rank and then you're collect
you're gonna collect everything
right so let's say rook c3 just rook b7
and then rook f7
and there are gonna be so many uh
checkmate threats
right and so that's why
fabiano caruana finally didn't go for
knight c4 instead he went for rook c5
and for this point magnus carlsen plays
like a machine he's like a machine all
the time he goes for c4 which is a
very natural move now f5 from fabiano
caruana
and king e2 from magnus carson
now he wants to bring the key into the
action king e7
and now i want you to think for a plant
with the white pieces but
because okay this is very very beautiful
we are an extra point here in this
position we're enjoying live with a
mojito
in our balcony right in miami miami
beach
by the way it was so expensive when i
visited
when i visited miami for spanish yeah i
remember
i was with my colleague with divas
international master
and we went for a dinner you know and i
took like 100 bucks you know
for for the whole night you know we
wanted to go for dinner
and then to the song club you know to
dance something to take some drinks
but uh you know we sit in some place
just in miami beach and then we are
there one
uh pasta plate each and one salad
and one sangria you know that was like
190 bucks you know
so you know i had spent all the money i
wanted to spend for the whole night
just one one one plate of faster you
know
but it was one of my best trips you know
because somehow
some friends managed to get uh us
tickets for
nadal versus federer the finals you know
my masters miami masters you know that
was a fantastic experience
exactly miami you have a church only if
you are breathing that's right
uh yeah so kim moves over to protect the
queenside pawns
freeing the pieces to infiltrate that's
a great plan mark and tracy johnson
this is precisely what magnus carlsen
did so at some point you gotta do
something
one idea is just uh as uh mark says just
to protect the pawn on c4
so you're freeing one piece and this is
what mike
magnus carlsen goes for he goes king d3
but i was actually impressed by uh
this move because he played it so
quickly and i was thinking
what happens after rook c8 for me it
looked like
magnus will have to go back to e2
because there are so many discovered
checks here for example knight c4 is a
move
but what do you play here in case fabi
goes for rook g8
what do you think on duda beating magnus
that was a historical moment right
because magnum had
a strike of 125 games without losing
you know that meant like almost for two
years you know i
i don't manage even to get like three
wins in a row you know
for me a strike doesn't last like more
than a week you know
so king c3 well king c3 yeah
but i don't know where you're going with
the skin for example now rook d
to c8 and what you're gonna do probably
you gotta go back to d3 otherwise
knight c4 is just coming right so king
c3 is not
and kidney 2 is just we go back to the
previous position
now black goes back to rook v8 and then
we have an improved thing
so kind d4 this is just too dangerous
guys
this is just too dangerous don't don't
be uh leonidas yes spartan king yeah
just uh
when you're in a party maybe but 94 is
just checkmate in one move so
don't go to too far away right so
that's why i was so impressed with
magnus carlsen you know because for him
it was this looked so natural but to me
after rook d8 i was thinking i will have
to go back
but the thing is i'm gonna tell you the
move the thing is
you don't need to move the kin this is
this is amazing you just need to
move the knight to b3 and there is no
proper discovery mode for example let's
say knight c4 check just kidney 2
and now the knight is pinned you're
attacking the rogue on c5 and black
loses on the spot
so knight b3 that's enough black has to
retreat the rook and then we
push with c5 okay i can understand that
a strong player sees this
but magnus just played king d3 like in
in in 30 seconds that's why
it keeps impressing me all the time you
know
do you think danny dubois is the best
current russian chess player
well i think rishuk uh is also
peter switzer grishouk nepomiachi
kayaking also duboff dubois i will say
is very strong in rapid
time controls but i think for example
nepal miachi is
one step ahead of danny dubois but of
course danny dubois is extremely strong
and
a very creative player and i love his
games you know
artemis as well so russian team is a
little bit dangerous right
so king d3 and caribana doesn't go for
rook d8
instead he brings the key into the
action king d7 and now
rook c3 well i was about to ask you this
question but what do you think
is the idea behind rook c3
let's see if you guys finds the plan
find the plan sorry
jorge ray dominguez mark and tracy
johnson joel
that's right blue rook b3 so
black has an active rook we have two
passive rooks protecting the ball on c4
but the king on d3
allows us to freeze some pieces because
after tetr the trait of rooks on b3
we got two pieces protecting c4 black
has two pieces attacking c4 so there's
no trouble
so that's why this plant which looks
like so
innocent it's so strong you know that's
why sometimes looks like magnus calzone
is basically doing nothing
and i don't know how he manages to to to
to beat like super strong gms like if
they were babies
right so
that's right we have an extra pawn so we
just need to prevent contemplate that's
right arya
so in this position caruana was already
desperate
he was low on time and he went for rogue
c6
so c5 from magnus carson attacking this
knight he
uh well he
he goes for another step now this knight
is going back to e8 now he's got a
passive knight
and now magnus carlsen improves this
knight from d2
now this knight from d2 was in a passive
role just protecting carlitos we call in
the spanish commentary
we call this spawn carlitos you know we
got two pawns well three points
aristotelis great philosopher
carlitos to see upon and fakundo the f
so knight three now this knight is
actually threatened threatening a fork
on e5
and uh black has to do something about
that and caruana goes for rook a6
and magnus carlsen goes for knight e5
check
attacking f7 king e7
and king e2 now again another fantastic
move from carlson
now he frees this d3 square for the
knight in case
black goes for f6 the knight on d3 is
fantastically placed because
not only prevent black from going rook
b2 but also protects the c5 pawn
so knight f6 from faviano caruana
probably is trying to
bring this knight to the action by a t5
and
drook one to c2 from carlson again
preventing counter play from our
opponent knight t5
and rook d3 everything's covered
and now at some point we are ready to
push the c pawn right
so rook c8 from favi and rook b3
from carlson so now that black has to
uh well pay attention to the c pawn now
we occupy
the open file and now after knight d3
all our pieces are extremely well
coordinated right
so rook c7 from favi rook b7 was a
threat
and now just rook c4 improving step by
step
the pieces now a4 is going to be
possible maybe rook b5 later
also some rook h4 lift to to attack the
h6 pawn
of course we're gonna take uh we're
gonna
take attention to this pawn on c5 right
so
rook a5 from fabi caruana he wants to
take carlitos but we always protect
carlitos
and that's why magnus carlsen goes for
the knight d3
peppa do you think that is possible that
real madrid create a chess club do you
see it as a possibility
of course you know and i don't know if
you guys
have seen the chess bundesliga so the
german league if one of the most
one of the strongest leagues in the
world and actually
i played one of the chess games in the
in a stadium football stadium
because berlin is a classic
from the german league they have a chess
team also bayern munich has a chess team
and also sampaoli which is a a team from
hamburg which plays in in the second
league
so it's pretty amazing so would be nice
or maybe the nba teams in the us right
creating some chess teams right so
sharing card with lebron james will be
quite awesome by the way congrats to
lebron james
the lakers won the lake right in a
pretty special
uh year after uh sadness from uh
kobe bryant so messy playing chess
that's right
[Laughter]
uh i don't know if you guys know about
kikisetian he's the dt
from from barcelona he was the dt of
barcelona he is a
very decent player he's got 20 60 rating
points feeder rating points so he's a
very decent player
also grandero from real madrid he's a
very decent player he's
he's he has actually participated in our
streams
in spanish commentary okay knight d3 e5
now this is desperation from faviano
caruana
the position is completely completely
hopeless sorry so for example some
plants
with a4 rook b5 are coming and faviano
caruana says you know what
i gotta do something about this because
uh this is just too much pressure so
he tries to okay give at this point but
in return taking this pawn from c5 and
again magnus calzone plays
extremely fast with the move knight
takes e5
chess was always big in germany that's
right i lived there for three years
in germany it's a really nice country
everything is well organized you know
transport system
salary conditions are proper and working
conditions are
great you know it's a flexible country
you can
go to your office uh at 8 a.m or 10 a.m
if you want doesn't matter
so it's actually a great country
but i was missing the good weather you
know in spain we have a lot of sun you
know
and we actually live in the streets so
that's why i came back to spain after
three years working the university of
hamburg so 95 rook takes e5 takes takes
and rook b7 for carlson and he's getting
a second pawn
and this is actually game over keaney
six knight f7
and magnus is two pawns up now the a7
pawn
is just well under attack as well also
h6
and this is just a nightmare for fabi
rook a5
knight d8 check so rook b3
magnus carlsen protects everything
and now this knight is ready to jump to
b7 for a fork or to f7 to grab the a6
pawn
so is there any indian seeing this life
check may are you
indian well i can say something in hindi
absent
because i was living with an indian in
my masters his name was anand
and he was actually a neighbor of uh of
in in chennai knight f7 king c5 and
knight e5
and now magnus carson is just bringing
this knight to
the center of the board and after few
moves
fabiano caruana had to resign here
knight f4 another precise move for for
for for uh carlsen and caruana decided
to give up in this position after knight
f4 you can take with the pawn but also
rook before followed by rook f4
guarantees why that decisis position so
we still have 15 minutes
so how about we solve some artistic
and famous puzzles
from ready as you guys know
ready well makes some uh
made some interesting contributions to
opening theory
and uh with the move knight f3 which is
one of my favorite openings the retti
uh he was also a great player and he was
also a great composer and
yeah this is very famous right this is
quite easy but
the next one or maybe the next one after
the next one
won't be that easy right so probably you
know this
puzzle well white is going in this
direction black is going in this
direction this looks like
what is going on here pepe like this is
just a stupid puzzle because black
just stops c spawn and now black is
going to promote this pawn on h1
well there is a way to
make a draw here and i see we have a lot
of you students here
in the chat and are you surprised by how
well fiducia is doing in the classical
games
man i was uh so surprised when he beat
magnus carlsen in the in the banta blitz
cap i don't know if you guys
uh followed about the blitz cup it was
actually our invention
in spanish chess 24 section
so the first edition was only in spanish
it was so successful that we wanted to
extend it to english too
so at the end was one of the the most
exciting tournaments in the world right
magnus carlsen was facing the fiducia in
the finals
and he bit magnus actually i was doing
commentary on that final i was so
excited you know it was
such an amazing final but i thought he
wouldn't
be so strong in the classical time
controls but he's proven
me that i'm wrong right with this
amazing tournament that he's playing
he's second right now after mike
wisconsin still two rounds ago
and uh right so how do we play yeah
so this puzzle proves that the straight
line
straight line is not always uh
the quickest path in chess right because
as you guys know to reach for example
this square
from h8 to h4
you can reach it by going straight line
with eight seven eight six h5 and h4 you
need one two three four move but you can
also do
one two three and four
so that's why geometry is kind of
different in chess
right so in this position black
moves and makes draw so it goes king g7
h4 and king f6
whoa so what happens here well
if black goes h3 which looks winning now
we go keaney six
and suddenly we're going to promote as
well
this one h2 c7
black tries to spot just to stop that
one and now keen g7
and this is a draw but this is not the
most astonishing variation because
now you could think that actually black
jazz plays a
king b6 stops the pawn now black's ready
to uh continue with a3 so what do we
what do you sorry what do you play here
with the white pieces
you go for kidney six you go for kidney
five
or what kidney five
who votes for kidney six nobody is
giving one euro or dollar or backs for
kidney six nobody voting for kidney six
so that's right king e5 this is a
fantastic move guinea six is just
garbage
as aryan is saying right king e5 what
are the threats
okay if we manage to get f4 the king to
f4
then we stop this pawn so if black takes
takes orion c6
now we just play king f4 and then we
stop that pawn if black goes
a3 again we're gonna promote with the
move
king d6 h2 c7
h1 c8 draw king b7 king d7
draw so
okay this is very well known puzzle
right this is just a little bit for
warming up
do you guys know this puzzle black plays
and makes draw in this position well
so basically this is also very tough
right because black is just
going in this direction and also black
is just stopping
this pawn from be5
so who knows this puzzle cheskin
yeah ready made this that's right
cheskin
and so i got plenty of this
artistic and games which i i'm gonna
show you maybe in the next
lectures yes so the next tuesday right
so today's tuesday i don't know where i
live anymore
i don't know where i live and yes
today's
tuesday right it's already wednesday in
spain
but okay king g7
king e7 but what's the idea you're gonna
see the whole line
what's the idea
it's not bali just to play the first
move right and then hope for the best
you really have to calculate everything
in this position
the same ready idea that's right my man
aryan is
that's right we need to get closer to b5
so because you have to change your mind
so it doesn't mean that
you run to this part of the board it
doesn't mean that you are not trying to
stop this pawn
because probably from this uh from this
square
you can also reach g1 like with the same
velocity right
as if you go in the straight line so
you go e7 this is clear that you're
gonna lose after b5
let's say king g7 just g5 g4 g3
g2 g1 that's equipped so
you're gonna go e7 and you go keen g7
just go g5 again keen f6 g4
uh what you're gonna do you're just
losing
so that's why the best move is king e7
what's the threat the threat is to go
keen f6 in the next move
e7 for example if black does something
stupid let's say king
b6 yes kin f6 attack this pawn black has
to protect it
e7 bishop b5 and now we take this pawn
with a draw
so that's why king e7 now black plays g5
now we continue with king g6 black plays
g4 and now what do you play
what do you play here with the white
pieces this is a key moment again
king c5 are you sure
knc5 think about it
chess game voting for kinsey five aryan
good luck voting for king c5
well 100 sure you'll bet your house on
this
you want to buy your house against me
i'll bet my house
uh okay so yeah
i saw somebody who gave the correct
solution
mr south london that's right
so king c5 is just losing because now we
forgot
that the the white the black bishop
can't stop e8 from
h5 so now g3 e7
and h5 and we lose it
so that's why we cannot play king c5 we
have to force
first bishop b5 and now king c5 just win
in a temple
let's say bishop b8 and now king d4 we
are
in the square right so you need to
draw a square to see you're able to
stop the pawn and now let's say king b6
black is not on time to capture the pawn
and protect this pawn at the same time
this was a nice puzzle right let's say
kini three king c5
king four and black is not on time so
only move here to keep in the game
bishop
d7 and now e8 promoting forcing this
bishop to go there now king g4 and
that's the draw
that's why puzzles you know are not so
easy
and now i'm gonna show you the last one
the last one
stopping the punks we could name this
puzzle wow
oh my ass is you know
it's hurting you know i've been sitting
here like for 12 hours today i was
i was recording a video series in the
morning then
working in my engineering project and
doing commentary in spanish
for no hs for five hours then teaching
some kids class
and now here with you guys
so now keen f2 kintex g2
it's white to move of course
so it's it's uh sorry why tomorrow why
to move why to move
that's right
pepe who do you see as a bigger
challenger for magnus carlsen alireza
ferruzza
wei yi or nihal sarin actually why he is
a little bit disappeared from the
from the chess tournaments i think he
started to study at the university
and he doesn't play so much
in the last months let's say
and he has still very young he's
extremely strong
he's very humble i have met him in
different tournaments
as a commentator i was there he was
playing and he's very very
nice and very strong but still i think
there is difference between fedutsa and
nihal sareen i think we all agree
and well let's think about
well the first move that comes to your
mind let
i think we all agree right this skin
takes e2
it's kintex g2 jeffrey shawn yeah it's a
super strong player from the states i
agree yeah
king g2 who votes for kng2 in the chat
hassle votes for king g2
az votes for kng2 somebody else
so basically there are like three
candidates move let's say
one is king h2 king f2 or king g2 moving
the rook doesn't you know
help at all and don't capture this pawn
okay because e1 queen it's winning on
the spot
so yeah
sometimes the logic like it shouldn't be
the easiest move
sometimes that logic works yeah so in
this case king g2
it's mistake let's try to understand why
so key in e4
so white kind of captured this one on c2
and now
keen f2 and what do you play here with
the black pieces
black plays and makes a draw
oh mctal there in the youtube channel
it's a well-known user in chess24 i'm
also
these shows are going to be in chess 24
as well guys
so in the shows page
uh this show it's embedded so you can
chat over there as well i'll be training
i'll be paying attention to to to that
chat as well
i want to hear ratchata but for that i
had to play some games
we're gonna stream as well some body
bleed sessions
it's uh quite a bunch of hours so
we'll have time for the rata to tie yeah
right so e1 jorge that's right
e1 beautiful pass right king d3
it's not working because of kini one and
now king c3 only move king to c2
kim b2 king d2 and now white is on time
so that's why only move e1
now white is forced to take with the kin
if we take with the rook there is king
d3
there's nobody that can't stop king d2
with the throw
zucchini one akin d3 and now there's
some kind of suspense for white
so if you go with the king to f2 f1 they
skin d2 with the chair with the draw
if you go rook a1 you can just
waste another tempo with king c3
threatening king b2 and if rook c1
just skin d3 with a throw so that's why
king g2 is not working
you're gonna play key in f2 and now this
is gonna get even more beautiful guys
so kini four kin take c2 and now
kd4 this is very very tough
what do you play here with white
it's not easy i'm gonna tell you this
the idea is very very beautiful
king f2 okay let's let's uh let's uh
first start with kindly two
right so key in e4 again and after king
c kintex c2 just key in e3 followed by
knf2 with a draw
so king d2 doesn't work
key in f2 doesn't work because of king
d3
so
i mean i spent like 15 minutes trying to
solve this puzzle yeah that's right
aryan
rook g1 and somebody could say
what's india behind rook g1 well of
course
now if uh
if black goes key in c3 i believe we can
just go keen e3
and after king b2 just king d2 and black
and white wins
and if black goes king e4 what do we
play we are in the same situation right
the rook was on c1
and we were in this position the rook is
on g1 and we are in this position
and now there's a fantastic move
the idea is to cut the king on the e
file
rook c1 we're in the same position
that's right chess game rook e1 this is
just a fantastic move what's the idea
somebody could say well now it's to cut
the king this is a rat
move right because now if king d4 we
cut the king
and then this king cannot help this guy
and then we capture calmly this
pawn on c2 and then we go back to get
the g2 pawn
if black goes kin f4 then we do the same
thing but on the other flank
key and f2 we kept the king we get this
pawn
and yeah black could play the smart guy
yeah by playing king e5
but now we continue doing the same thing
king
e3 and now whenever black goes key in f5
we go king of two
whenever black goes king d5 we go king
d2
that was an interesting puzzle right
that was quite quite beautiful
and yeah
so this is the idea to waste a temple
with kin f2 then to waste another tempo
with rook g1 and finally bring the rook
to e1
so i think this is all
we've been here for one hour more or
less and we've seen
the game between magnus carlsen and
fabiano caruana from round four of
norwich's
and uh we've seen three interesting
puzzles
from ready artistic puzzles
so richard ready not john noon
richard ready one of the best chess
players in the beginning of the 20th
century actually i have a plane guys
in three hours i have a plane no
in four hours so i guess i can sleep
like two hours then pack my
baggage and then go to the airport and
tomorrow i guess i'll see you
no tomorrow i don't see you but anyway
i'll be streaming
all of these days here in this channel
and
uh hopefully we'll learn some
interesting thing together
and also i'll play against you in banter
blitz sessions
so it's been a nice pleasure
as usual to be with all of you and uh
yes see you in the next time yeah see
you in the next video
have a go have a good evening guys and
take care yeah
bye